[Musique]
la grande interview sur le plateau de
rtl france installé exceptionnellement
dans le cadre du grand forum économique
de saint pétersbourg avec maintenant
yves thibault de silguy bonjour bonjour
vous êtes ancien commissaire européen
dont vous connaissez tout ce qui se
passe à bruxelles
et ça va être important la donne des
explications que vous allez mener pour
comprendre un peu la situation entre la
russie et l'europe
vous êtes administrateur de sable nombre
de grandes entreprises françaises lvmh
j'en passe se angie non à 20 si vous
êtes administrateur ci de là de la
deuxième banque ici à btb btb
donc vous êtes un intermédiaire entre le
monde économique français et le monde
économique
un russe un des intermédiaires je crois
pas non mais un observateur observateurs
mais on passe par vous voilà est-ce que
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette idée
de ce qui circule ici ce bruit qui
consiste à dire
bon le climat politique est un fameux il
est un peu compliqué mais l'économie
tient bon et l'économie a intérêt à se
tenir bien pour sortir de ce qu au but
le plus rapidement possible et donc la
relation entre la russie et le reste du
monde doit s'améliorer
bah oui on peut l'espérer ceci dit ce
que je constate c'est qu'elle a plutôt
quand même tendance à se détériorer
depuis un certain temps indépendamment
du coc vide
les relations politiques entre l'europe
les etats-unis et la russie ne sont pas
dans une phase je trouve aujourd'hui
d'amélioration ça c'est le premier
élément
deuxièmement vous avez raison c'est vrai
le
les économies a plutôt bien résisté au
co vide en russie vous être normal sauf
la partie énergique quand même très
important qui inquiète a perdu une
partie de ses clients
si elle n'avait plus d'avoir misé
horizon arrivé à traverser avoir
traversé les grandes entreprises
françaises sont restées ça malgré la
détérioration du climat politique de ces
dernières années l'a encore vu ce matin
au forum franco russe elles investissent
encore je pense que en revanche tout ce
qui est fait est me tei c'est à dire les
petites et moyennes entreprises sont
moins présentes et la dynamique de
développement qu'on avait connu au début
des années 2000
cette dynamique est arrêté pour une
raison d'ailleurs qui est très simple
qui est liée aux sanctions et notamment
aux sanctions américaines
car aujourd'hui venir travailler en
russie nouer des partenariats pose des
problèmes dans la mesure où vous pouvez
être confronté à un partenaire qui est
sous sanction notamment américaines et
comme les américains et appliquent leur
loi à l'étranger comme ils l'ont fait
dans le miroir mais là c'est dissuasif
les entreprises ont beaucoup de mal à
surmonter cet obstacle si elles ont les
moyens ce cas des grosses entreprises
alors avec des cabinets d'avocats
il arrive à trouver les situations jeu
mais c'est cher et c'est dissuasif et
qu'est ce qui ne va pas dans les
relations entre la russie et l'europe
dans trois cas il ya quand même
historiquement une méfiance qui
remontent à la guerre froide
il ya d'autre part des comportements qui
sont donnés aux uns et aux autres par
l'autre partie qui donnent l'impression
qu'ils à un dialogue très difficile on
reproche à horus ne pas faire ci de
faire ça ne pas faire si les russes de
leur côté reproché et donc je dirais
aujourd'hui on voit pas mettre tiers ce
qui est demandé aux russes par les
européens est probablement pour des
raisons je suis rassemblement de
politique intérieure difficilement
négociables donc je vois pas très bien
aujourd'hui ce qui permettrait de
reprendre
est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer comme
un certain nombre d'industriels que la
politique c'est une chose avec sa propre
logique et que l'économie a elle aussi
ses logiques ses objectifs et ses
contrats c'est vrai c'est vrai mais ça
en ce qui concerne les entreprises
françaises c'est vrai pour les grandes
entreprises sont sentis soir jour là
sont toujours là et en resteront là
elles ont investi mais elles ont les
moyens juridiques financiers elles ont
aussi des partenariats de longue date
donc c'est elle reste par contre
le commerce ne se développe pas ah non
il ya encore qui m'ont fait entre la
france je pense et la russie et
deuxièmement l'arrivée des nouveaux
investissements la création d'emplois
c'est petit et ça c'est pour le moment
je valent la peine de le voir dans les
chiffres que j'entends on assista on est
sur un plateau est stable ça se
maintient mais il n'y a pas on a cassé
ce vin ce développement qui avait
aujourd'hui arrêter parce que les
sanctions d'origine très souvent
américaines ont pesé là dedans parce que
on a le sentiment que globalement quand
même on les assume et on s'en arrange
oui mais c'est son art on joue et on
s'arrange on s'en rendra peut-être moins
d autres menaces obstruction oui qui
arrive on s'en arrange on s'en arrange
néanmoins de plus en plus difficilement
et en faisant des montages juridiques
extrêmement compliqué donc il faut que
coûte très cher donc c'est ça qui est
dissuasif pour la la pme
ouh ouh là le t il à moyennes
entreprises de même les sanctions elles
ne s'allège pas elles vont quand même en
se renforçant sans cesse arrive un
moment où ça va je pense gêner davantage
encore les entreprises présent
européennes présentes en russie
est-ce que l'européen que vous êtes
connaissant le fonctionnement de
bruxelles croit plausible les nouvelles
menaces de sanctions qui porterait
carrément sur le système de financement
international souich dont bénéficient
aujourd'hui je n'ai la rue en état je
peux pas me prononcer en détail ce que
je peux dire c'est que le système de
sanction est un système efficace pour
les américains en tout cas et dans une
certaine mesure pour les européens pour
espérer faire sur des choses mais c'est
comme toutes les menaces si vous en
faites un peu trop on ne les croit plus
voilà quand est on va arriver à ce stade
la question est ce que la russie a les
moyens de rebondir derrière le kobe
alors que je constate c'est que la
russie a commencé à tirer les leçons de
cette détérioration et des politiques de
sanctions
la russie maintenant joue très russe
c'est à dire que l produits russes en
matière agroalimentaire en matière
informatique cet art dont il ya eu un
gros gros efforts de la russie le
regarder chez moi aussi un climat sain
avec les chinois ils sont plusieurs
quand même puis d'accord mais il regarde
les chinois regardent les pays arabes
regardent tout le monde il discute avec
tout le monde c'est normal
en revanche ils sont quand même je crois
plus proche des européens que
culturellement que les chinois et est
facile pour eux je pense de travailler
avec les européens
vous avez été chinois mais aujourd'hui
ils développent une production nationale
et notamment ils font d'énormes efforts
en matière de digitalisation vous
entendez dans ce forum
les discours qu'ils ont fait est
effectivement moi je le vois bien
notamment dans le cadre de la bête et b
les investissements qui sont faits pour
se moderniser ils ont une main ils ont
une qualité
le collaborateur tout à fait remarquable
les cadres au moma des entreprises
russes sont formés dans des écoles
russes ou quelquefois un peu à
l'étranger mais sont de très très bonnes
qui est ce que ça veut dire qu'il
pourrait s'affranchir de la surpuissance
des gaffes a par exemple je suis pas
dire je ne vais pas dire capable de
répondre mais ce que je constate c'est
qu'en tout cas ils s'affranchissent de
la technologie européenne pont pour pour
se développer de plus en plus ça veut
dire sac à la sortie du produit dont on
connaît les grands vainqueurs 1 dès 9h
au curry profiter finalement entre
guillemets de la crise la chine s'en est
sorti très bien des traduite les états
unis s'en sont sortis moins vite mais
très bien ce qu'ils ont perdu c'est les
européens ces européens alors propre
mais pas trop cher en dépenses en ti
oiseaux on peut espérer que ça va
rebondir quand même avec tout l'argent
qui est en train d'être injectés
ouais moi je pense que personnel je
pense que l'on va avoir une croissance
probablement plus forte que ce que nous
donnent les instituts de sondage
avec un risque de voir comment savoir
pointe c'est l'impression que s'il ya
une croissance qui est tirée par la
demande ne se soit une bande biens de
consommation ou une demande
d'investissement si l'offre ne suit pas
conséquence c'est la montée des prix on
commence à voir des signaux qui
s'allument sur l'inflation sera encore
faible indice allure deuxièmement on
voit tous les jours je devais voir en
france dans la conduite des travaux dans
la conduite des commandes on n'a pas les
pièces détachées il ya des retards
d'approvisionnements ça à l'image et
donc je crois qu'il ya une demande
potentielle en europe extrêmement forte
et on a mis suffisamment de moyens sur
la table pour que cette demande se
mais je réalise que dans les échanges
internationaux là qu'on vient de décrire
l'europe toute entière peut continuer de
vivre dans la fidélité parfois aveugle
envers les américains et dans la
proximité géographique et culturelle de
la russie qu'on n'utilise pas oui c'est
difficile de répondre à votre question
parce que je pense pas que au niveau des
chais plus combien on est maintenant 27
28 27 27 27
on est tous là même la même attitude à
l'égard des on n'est pas
coordonnée
ah non c'est très difficile en termes de
poésie par ouï étrangères c'est très
difficile historiquement le plat pologne
c'est pas la france
historiquement et dans ses relations
avec l'allemagne et avec son télé russe
pas la même chose donc par conséquent il
ya quand même un poids du passé un poil
culturelle qui fait que l'attitude des
ce n'est pas la même pour ça que
l'europe elle progresse de manière
économique comme ces économies qu'elle
progresse quand ensemble on peut faire
face mieux à un problème que seule
pensée l'exemple de des vaccins on va en
parler mais c'est pas un secret la balle
à la russie joue le désert gorges est un
jeu wii si l'intéressé quoi nous en
jouant les accords des mois que la
russie s'est d'abord intéresse c'est la
russie
fait et ils ont une culture ils ont une
âme russe ils ont un passé qui fait la
russie c'est un pays très grand pays
avec réserve cette fierté nationale
cette image nationale cette identité
mais ils sont ils ont énormément évolué
sur le plan idéologique maintenant c'est
l'économie de marché ainsi qu'en russie
au même titre que chez nous il ya donc
par conséquent ils disent évoluent-ils
sadate lors leur grand défi c'est quand
même de de lever la la dépendance qu'ils
ont des matières premières notamment
énergétiques pour aller vers vers
l'industrialisation
quand vous entendez le la lumière
poutine quand vous voyez des forums
comme celui ci aujourd'hui ça a pour but
d'attirer les investissements étrangers
ces investissements viennent du golf de
la chine deux des états unis de la
région européenne
après tout ce qui importe c'est que les
gens viennent investir pour les doter
d'une puissance industrielle économique
donne d'innovation de la digitalisation
aujourd'hui suffisante pour répondre à
leurs besoins
ils ont pas ils sont un pays en tant que
tel donc là il cote ils ont en face des
partenaires comme on joue avec des
partenaires comme s'il avait plusieurs
fournisseurs
au fait qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis
j'allais dire trois quatre ans pour que
laissent les rapports se détériore un
peu
souvenez-vous lorsque le président
poutine était venu à paris il avait
invité présent macro qui t'est venue ici
d'ailleurs un à ce forum
il y avait des perspectives il ya une
affaire de la cri mais il ya eu la
sphère de l'ukraine à l'ue à faire des
droits de l'homme on attache une
importance très forte
en europe aujourd'hui aux valeurs on est
loin de la politique
gaullienne vous rappelez politique
gaullienne ça consistait à dire pas
d'immixtion dans les affaires
intérieures des autres pays
et puis à la fin des années 80 meilleur
soutien à gérard en agence pour des
humanitaires et des droits de l'homme et
droit de la bresse et la maintenance a
pris une sage ou un rôle colossal qui
n'est pas question d'avoir une attitude
aujourd'hui en europe qui serait de dire
d'un côté c'est une affaire purement
intérieure ça nous regarde pas ouais
enfin sauf qu'on se permet ce genre de
réflexion à l'égard de la russie on se
permet pas beaucoup à l'égard de la
chine c'est quoi ce soit qu'on ne voit
qu'eux quoique les ouïghours et les
nonos sait comment ça commence
est ce que est ce que les caisses qui
peut attirer encore aujourd'hui qu'est
ce qui attire les entreprises françaises
qui peuvent attirer d'autres hauts
responsables en russie c'est un très
grand marché
ouais c'est un marché de consommation
chez vous bien sûr 150 millions et et
vous avez entendu
peut-être ce matin
monsieur puyané qui avait trouvé après
un très beau développement très brillant
est au fond très fondée sur le fait que
le problème aujourd'hui énergétique de
la chine de la russie
ces deux décarbonés cette énergie mais
ça si ce discours de présidente total
ils vont investir
on sent bien que il parle à ses
actionnaires aussi ceux qui lui ont fait
un peu reproche donc les deux valises
est régulièrement et les rues sont
obligés de décarbonés comme les autres
est-ce que ça a été leur première
préoccupation je crois aujourd'hui que
globalement dans le monde quand même il
ya un changement de mentalité
considérable que par rapport à la
signature de l'accord fut drôme et à 21
les espions énorme on a des choses à
leur vendre là pour accélérer la
décarbonisation euro probablement
intérêt a aussi affaire de la
décarbonisation donc c'est une nécessité
qui s'impose à tout le monde on a un
savoir faire on n'est pas les seuls
sûrement bon à savoir faire on essaie de
vendre notre savoir faire
les as les entreprises françaises qui
ont un futur en russie ce sont celles
qui peuvent leur apporter à savoir faire
qui peuvent leur apporter une innovation
dont ils ont besoin après la question
est de savoir ce qu'elles resteront fois
qu'elles ont apporté leur savoir faire
est-ce qu'elles resteront c'est tout
l'enjeu de des 25 ou 30 prochaines
années je vous qui connaissez une fête
du ce le rop
comment vous voyez son évolution on n'a
rien à voir avec la russie si parce que
c'est par rapport à l'international
on n'arrive pas à trouver et à parler
d'une seule voix non mais aujourd'hui le
problème de l'europe c'est qu'on a été
jusqu'à l'an 2000 dans un processus
d'intégration on a été au summum de
l'intégration le cadre des trucs quand
on a lancé le monde
rappelez-vous en 2000 on a eu très forte
croissance dans les années qui ont suivi
et puis après pour toute une série de
raisons on a vu que ça partait par pan
il ya eu à y en a plus que l'euro allait
sauter il ya eu l'élargissement qui sont
faits dans des conditions donc se poser
la question
il ya eu les accords de schengen qui ont
éclaté depuis l'onglet qui sont partis
en les anglais ont rapporté beaucoup
plus assure que l'on n'aurait pas fait
l'euro sur le plan technique sans
l'apport des anglais ils ont été
extraits par les apporter beaucoup ils
apportaient une ouverture alors il
n'était pas d'accord non mais il n'était
pas dans l'euro en hausse de pendant
l'euro mais disait y voit qu'ils
allaient ils allaient arriver un jour en
98 quand on a lancé l'euro 31 décembre
il me disait épouse en 2002 on vous aura
rejoint ce qu'ils ont toujours rejoint
là non seulement une parole ou à l'euro
ils ont quitté l'europe et ça je dirais
car on a l'impression aujourd'hui et on
ne sait pas comment on va sortir de la
crise de la dette
je veux bien qu'on nous dise les traites
critères de maastricht où ça c'est
dépassé bon parfois ils ont été faits
alors bah oui les les taux d'intérêt
sont très bas donc il n'y a pas de
preuve alors on est dans un paradigme me
différents donc à ce moment là il faut
tout revoir et construire un mot parade
un nouveau système
ou alors au contraire ils sont encore
leur raison d'être est on est on est
loin des marques et on est loin des cool
j'ai eu un tag la commission disait qu
elle mettait encore entre parenthèses et
les critères de maastricht pendant deux
ans interpelle quand même ma mère
qu'elle prend la présidence de l'europe
qu'est ce qu'on peut en attendre
angela merkel va prendre la présidence
de conseil ou de conseil
mais bon ça vous embête federman merkel
s et l'allemagne ils sont réels à elle a
été toujours très européenne et elle a
surmonté des difficultés d'opinion
publique en prenant des pavés sur le
départ aussi de sa carrière je peux pas
juger deux de telle ou telle personne je
constate que les dirigeants allemands
depuis la fin de la guerre ont toujours
joué j'ai joué le jeu elle a obtenu
l'arrêt la zone xtrême à la veille de
changement dont on ne sait pas dans quel
sens en italie en france et trois plus
gros pays
oui d'accord mais c'est une autre
génération et on verra ce qui se passera
je crois que l'europe est à risque je
crois que l'europe était rist faut pas
oublier quand même que l'histoire de
l'europe qu'est ce que c'est ces
soixante dix ans de paix de prospérité
en un continent qui depuis deux mille
ans là c'était de s'entretuer c'est vrai
c'est vrai pourquoi est ce que cette
durée indéfinie portait donc les
tendances lourdes
le morcellement de l'europe est-elle en
termes de culture en termes de tout ce
que vous voulez
difficile de les faire converger ça a
été une idée de génie
à cause de la guerre et des horreurs de
la guerre qui fait qu'à ce moment là les
dirigeants dit on ne peut pas continuer
comme ça et le moment était propice pour
lancer un rapprochement
ça a été un succès mais les tendances
fondamentales est très lourde
ce n'est pas évident qu'elle aille dans
le même sens aujourd'hui je ne vois pas
de percée européenne alors je connais
mal les questions médicales je ne sais
pas si le coc vide a permis de mettre en
place une europe de ben oui votre aide
et on a mis en place une centrale
d'acheteurs relâche qui dans un premier
temps un très bel fonctionner c est ce
qu est l ce qu' il serait pas été le
moment de deux de faire beaucoup plus
dans le domaine de la santé
je me pose accueillant c'est une
question qui peut se poser à tous les
pays y compris la russie d'un oui mais
pas dans l'europe et dans l'europe
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire ensemble
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter la glissade
et çà et là on est à risque on est à
risque il c'est vrai qu'il ya eu des
comptes ya eu la crise en de financière
en 2008-2009
l'europe a bien réagi elle a pris un
certain nombre de décisions en matière
macroéconomique on a décidé un emprunt
européen
quand j'ai quitté bruxelles pour la
première du monde moi j'avais proposé à
ses parents après vous attend après ils
le font très bien ça n'avance pas
va-t-on enfin
donc moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui le
sursaut de l'europe
bah on l'attend enfin écoutez vous comme
on en a vu des sommets de crise où
aimaient et on s'est aperçu toujours au
dernier moment que la crise rendait
intelligent dernier moment très riche et
c'est vrai il ya un autre élément quand
même c'est que les générations qui était
au pouvoir étaient des générations qui
avait connu de près ou de loin la guerre
qu'ils avaient de la mémoire et donc et
pas le nouvel gephac est-il aussi dit
merci beaucoup merci la grande interview
c'est évidemment sur arte pour trouver
en replay vous retrouver sur les réseaux
sociaux et puis sur le site internet
arte arte france ce point tv à bientôt à
très bientôt
[Musique]